I started getting short of breath,
so definitely does attack
your respiratory system,
and it hits it hard.
So I think, like,
that was one of the worst symptoms,
because I woke up in
the middle of the night,
and I was disoriented. I
wasn't able to breathe.
I had a very high fever.
I also had started to pick up a dry cough.
Those are the only two signs
of anything coronavirus.
Unlike other colds and the flu that I had,
there was no headache,
no sneezing, no sniffles,
no sore throat, no body aches,
and even with that high
fever, no chills and sweats
that you usually get, that hot and cold.
I wasn't able to get anybody's attention,
and I think at that point,
you start sitting down
and having a conversation
with yourself, like,
OK, this is it for me.
This is it for me and my children.
I won't ever see them again-type of thing.
But I thank God that he was with me,
was able to wake him
up, wake my husband up
to let him know that
something wasn't right.
Biocontainment was weird.
I spent 10 days in there.
I was hooked up to all kinds of monitors.
Anyone entering my biocontainment,
it was like Neil Armstrong
landing on the moon.
They had full biocontainment suits on,
three layers of gloves,
a motor in their back to provide air,
duct tape all around, sealing off anything
that could possibly expose themselves.
I'm quite baffled as to why
people are interested at all.
I'm just this guy that's
got a positive diagnosis
with no symptoms stuck at home,
but I guess people are fearful,
and I'm sad about that.
I think I'm proof that even
if you catch the virus,
you can be just fine.
When I first got here, they
wasn't going to test me
because I didn't fit the criteria.
After some CAT scans
and a couple of tests,
they decided to go ahead and test me,
and they came back and they
told me that I tested positive.
My family is on 14-day quarantine.
I haven't seen my children,
haven't seen my husband in days now.
But there was nothing they could give me
other than ibuprofen and
gallons and gallons of Gatorade.
I kid that I've been through
every flavor of the rainbow
of Gatorade multiple amounts of times.
The light blue is the bomb.
Stay away from the grape. That's nasty.
There is no treatment for coronavirus,
so what they're treating is,
they can treat a symptom.
So if I have a fever, they
can treat it with Tylenol.
If I have a cough, they can
treat it with cough medicine.
But my body has to fight it off,
so I have to take the time to rest,
make sure that I'm trying to keep down
as much food as I can, and
let my body do its job.
I've been here, I think
I lost about 15 pounds,
so I don't know what I'll be looking like
when I get up out of here.
I got to get my hair done, you all.
Talk about my bonnet.
It feels quite surreal
to be part of this huge thing, actually.
I step back and, you know,
realize that, you know,
I see it's on the news.
It just dominates the
headlines everywhere.
We were out there.
There was a lot of hate that came at us.
There were some very
elaborate death threats
that mounted and got worse
as the days progressed,
as people learned that
the State Department
was going to allow us back to the States.
Everybody's making jokes about it.
I don't take it personal.
I think the only thing
that kind of bothered me
was to see myself on the news,
to see my local news station, you know,
speak of this situation,
but not even know wholeheartedly,
like, what was going on.
It's a lot scarier when
you see it on the TV
or when you read about it
than what it actually is. But
I'm not going to sit up here
and pretend like it's a joke.
Definitely has taken
me away from my family,
gave me some breathing problems,
and sat me down for a
while to reevaluate myself,
and kind of, you know, my life.
I know after this, you know,
I want to get out and do more.
All along, we were making
lemonade out of lemons,
looking at the glass half
full, not half empty,
living for the present, not
worrying about the past,
and also not focusing on the future
because all of that
was out of our control.
Stress is the biggest, biggest contributor
to battling the immune system,
and it's not good for the immune system.
So keeping our stress
level down was important.
So just make sure that you guys
are keeping your kids safe,
and you're keeping yourself safe as well.
That's the best advice
that I can give anybody.
Just make sure that you all are
paying attention to your body.
Your body will let you know
when something is wrong,
and if it's telling you something's wrong,
then go ahead and get tested.